blackhead podcast
with guap dad 4000 not to be confused
with guap daddy four thousand
yes please don't confuse don't ever call
him that we just did uh
we we just did a prank on you
with the elk boys and uh it almost went
left
yeah i'm happy it didn't
um well look it it ended up working out
well it was it was very funny
yeah shout out to jesse and those guys
um when we were actually like trying to
record the interview the fake interview
we were talking about show everybody
your nails you got the [ __ ] clear
polish on them things
yeah and they're shining how often do
you get your nails done
uh man i you got to do uh maintenance on
the coochie grippers at least
once a week every two weeks the coochie
grippers mm-hmm i like that
[Music]
the gucci correct the consensual coochie
grip every time
every time gotta be right every time 100
yeah that's
i think more dudes should get their
nails done yeah it needs to be sleeping
i think people it's just laziness and
it's just honestly i was raised
to go to the nail shop you were raised
that way yeah my
my dad and my mama [ __ ] with it tough
just going always have so they
always bring me i've been going which
side of your family is the filipino side
it's always the mama's side the mom's
side yeah yeah it's always the mama's
right right right right like you're like
who's the filipino dude bagging like you
know
a bad a bad lovely you know sister from
oakland
it's maybe in the bay like maybe like
maybe pilo right like maybe pilo
oh for sure like maybe yeah definitely
not nico
definitely not nico he can't even get
the third camera working yeah he's
yeah he had to learn the language worst
[ __ ] producer ever
um i'm just playing an ego i love you yo
so uh you know you're embracing
the filipino side you're doing an album
with the with 88 rising and
you know you you were telling me you did
like the virtual festival yeah
yeah it was super tight we we
wanted to bring this album to ada rising
because
of the filipino aspect and uh kind of
like the next step aspect i feel like
i love a lot of their narrative content
and a lot of their story based stuff
their documentary stuff and their videos
are crazy
it's just amazing and i already got
crazy videos so it's tight
for me to connect with them with a team
that i already came up with is
chris simmons and the people that we we
use on our shoots
and be competing and swinging at the
same level yeah some of this stuff
you were saying earlier that like pinch
was like the common denominator
to kind of you know maybe connect you
guys a bit it was a lot of things but
that was like the first one because he
was performing at that festival
heading the cloud sting and uh i was in
his trailer
navigating meeting people when i ran
into bryant
we met physically for the first time
then we had already had mutual people
just because of duckworth and the homie
drew banger from the bay
you uh it's crazy because i told this to
brian like um
what was that album he put out niko a
couple years ago sailor
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy but i feel like
he like
kind of like really improved as a
[ __ ] rapper like heavily like no
he's dope yeah and i feel like you've
always been dope as a rapper but i feel
like people haven't seen you in that
light
and i feel like you know obviously the
dreamville thing helped but i also feel
like the quarantine bars
like you rapping on instagram oh yeah
ronan wraps the rona wraps whatever you
were doing
was [ __ ] it's dope because i think it
like
first of all perfect bit to do for you
know
the pandemic especially because you were
doing that [ __ ] early yeah like right
off the rip
but i also think it kind of just
showcased like your like your
capabilities
as an mc did you get a lot of love like
hella love
i got i got all the love i was i feel
like i was supposed to get
um or that i could merit at the time
from that
i do still wish that i could have did
more episodes but
it just was so hard to manage after a
certain point just like hounding [ __ ]
down to wrap in a house
as soon as the world started opening up
where we thought it was
that ronald raps was done yeah you were
like early like when we was really like
hunkered down at the crib watching tiger
games
figured that [ __ ] out a week into me
being home
it was sam's idea nice sam brought it up
because i told him
we was trying to plan content and i told
him i wanted to do freestyles and [ __ ]
so he was like you might as well
freestyle with your partner's dad home
too
yep it was like joey badass was on there
mm-hmm whiz whiz chris brown buddy
currency uh earth gang
um mers was there someone who's like
brown
sent you their rap and you were like
[ __ ] mike he he bothered me this week
currency currency it's better yes bit is
another another currency went so
did so tight for one that he cut
time off the end of his verse sent it
again he was i rapped too long the first
time
because this [ __ ] just caught a body
while he was playing with his hot wheels
in his closet and started freestyling
that's some real currency
yeah currency's original verse for
runner ups that he sent me was like
three minutes long
oh [ __ ] no he rapped forever and i was
like i mean
it's too long for us to post up
i know i was telling people there is no
limit but currency really likes
so it's like some of the people who did
the rona wraps like some of those people
you don't have music with
so i'm assuming you're fans of them like
yeah i mean to my knowledge you and
currency don't have music
no we do you do okay yeah currency did a
project uh with dj fresh shot at dj
fresh
from the bay um and i was featured on
there
i got a song called easy hard with
currency it's actually one of my best
best get my best guess first nurses yeah
if you know spit is on it you got to
come with your [ __ ] oh fish
i skated on that [ __ ] i skated floated
i love that verse
and the fans love it too like people
really enjoy that uh talk about the
title of the upcoming album
and why it is like give us the
background of the title it's called 1176
and that is the address of the house
that i grew up in
in oakland um i know a lot of people
have attachments like if you if we look
at all the album covers a lot of people
have attachments to like
the childhood homes yeah yeah and baby
pictures and [ __ ] so this is my
my version of that but personal project
yeah a way more
you know all the way me way it's like my
my full narrative
and i feel like uh i really wanted to
get this off my chest so i could move
past it creatively
just about talking about my origins
because that's what the album is really
it's an origin story for me where i'm
able to talk about certain things that
hurt me certain things that helped me
certain things that got me lit just my
whole lifestyle before i moved to l.a
do you think cause you're known for i
would say like
people know you as a personality as a
character
right they know you to be [ __ ]
hilarious the scammer [ __ ] all that
does that ever hurt you as an artist
like having
have you ever like ran into issues where
you feel like people didn't take you
serious because they look at you more as
like
the funny ass dude has that ever been
something you've noticed happening
yeah i mean people have done that all my
life
it's just it's just like it's like it
that way when you i feel like when you
look the way
i do and you carry yourself the way i do
i'm always in between worlds
yeah like i always been the kind of
creative eclectic kid
at the same time i'm from oakland you've
seen how i was trying to do blood
like it's it's really a duality that
come in my existence
and that's part of the fault of people
not being fully tapped in with that so
i don't i don't blame them i'm not mad
at it it was a time when that was
frustrating but
uh that didn't last too long right
and i feel like i feel like two just
like the last couple of years some of
the looks and like people who have
co-signed you and
you know i feel like that probably
alleviated some of that as well honestly
the dreamville [ __ ] to keep it a honey
the dream building that was like my last
chip on my shoulder where like i went
there trying to
trying to like prove that you belong i
belong
and i am one of the best [ __ ] that it
can make a song
that y'all can invite right and
after that and then we went to the
grammys and now oh [ __ ]
i i started moving different creatively
still i'm learning how to scale back
certain aspects of just like being hella
good
to make to make the overall experience
of the song more enjoyable because
sometimes you gotta pull punches you
know of course
but like that comes with time so i
i'm not mad at people for trying to f
it's human nature to look at this
as an ashtray and not as a cup holder
you know what i'm saying there could be
a cup holder it could i could have put
my
i actually want to move this cup because
it's it's empty and it looks ghetto
you know we could just get rid of it see
if nico can dispose of a cup he can't
get the third camera working but
see if he can [ __ ] throw away we
finna roast nico about that third camera
this whole podcast um yeah no like
with the dreamville thing who who from
dreamville was it eve was it like who
was it that originally
like tapped in with you to become a part
of the uh the revenge of the dreamer
sessions
[ __ ] cold it was called yeah that was
the original thing
i met cole uh at the nice guy
leaving uh drake's new year's thing and
he was like yo
take my number down before you leave and
i texted him
immediately and he texts me back right
everyone says that and then
it was so crazy to me i was like i tell
that story every time because nobody's
ever done that
right nobody especially even people who
i'm closer friends with
now like bryson my man bryson it took
him
a minute to text me back and i'm hella
cool i'm closer to bryson i am cold
but that just when he texts me back like
that
i was like damn i [ __ ] with that
a hell of [ __ ] with that and the homie
ryan at the time who
i was [ __ ] around with from a
previous a label situation
shout out fly rye was also in and around
the dreamville camp so we had code
bringing me up
right like oh no i know that [ __ ] come
on
and then it just kind of fell into place
it worked out beautifully you got a
grammy nomination
right [ __ ] that's forever forever
forever forever ever yeah that's crazy
um you know the other thing too that i
wanted to talk to you about because with
the pandemic
you know you kind of came into the game
kind of uh
being noses as a scammer mm-hmm you know
what i mean mm-hmm
kind of yeah it was that was his thing
that was the thing yeah for sure
it's still it's still a part of me like
i'm i'm revealing
uh chapters of myself as they come and
as i figure out how to express
them creatively you know so at first i
came out it was the internet thing
that's what i was on
i was [ __ ] trying not to scam and i'm
just an internet baby at heart
so that's what people see me as then it
was a rapper because i really want to be
one of the [ __ ] tightest [ __ ] that
was barred up so that's what [ __ ] were
saying for me and now i'm
kind of opening up the full envelope to
just you know
just making good timeless [ __ ] yeah but
i'm wondering what the
you know with the pandemic the [ __ ]
edd [ __ ] is booming
booming like i got friends of mine that
like
have made like six figures during the
pandemic off of the edd [ __ ] and i'm
like
afraid for them because i'm like dude
you guys are kind of turning up a little
bit much
yeah like would there be any sort of
advice you'd give to anybody who's
watching this that might be
dabbling in that because you know it's
definitely
it seems like it's very easy yeah to get
a
like off that [ __ ] right now all scams
is
uh i mean for what's available
to the urban community that is a part
of the market share of fraud
all those available or like ready
available are all relatively pretty easy
when it comes to the edd and any type of
current scams i don't know anything
about none of that [ __ ]
but if i had to give advice to somebody
it would be
stay off instagram yeah man that's the
thing people you people be
flossing their [ __ ] like you saw the guy
who shot the music video
oh he he i don't like the slander [ __ ]
right but he was an absolute idiot the
worst
he was probably the one of the dumbest
[ __ ] that we've ever seen
ever who could do that like that's he
he's i look at him the same way some
[ __ ] in the bay
just killed two girls and went live on
instagram i saw that you've seen that
yeah somebody he's
he's the same he's the same type of
[ __ ] he's just his song was catchy
but that's the same thing this is a
crime dog yeah
and you just snitched on yourself you
just snitched on yourself in the act
when the when the lake is hot
and told him where he was at this [ __ ]
was on rodeo
and he was still there showing the
envelopes and [ __ ]
yeah like what the some people are just
stupid but i mean that's darwinism no
was that you know obviously that guy did
that
for clicks for for clout it was
clickbait and i feel like when you first
came out i feel like that
like when i when people first kind of
became hip to you i feel like that was
the peak of
the internet [ __ ] dictating who was
getting signed
you know that was like it was almost
like this battle between like
does the music even [ __ ] matter
anymore or is it the antics
because [ __ ] like you know ig
comedians were getting record deals
yeah and [ __ ] and the music was not good
you kind of i feel like we're like a pic
perfect mixture of like
both worlds because you kind of figured
out how to be like funny on the internet
but your [ __ ] was dope yeah but was that
ever like something like
because i feel like to be a dope mc
and and to try to make it in that world
and to not have personality which you
obviously have it had to have been
frustrating but you know obviously
you had both both sides covered but but
that era
i would say like 2016 2017 early 2018
like
it just was i feel like it was like a
dark era for music for like the industry
it definitely was it was a dark
era for creativity as a whole
we were coming out of the soundcloud era
and all
of the champions from this whole new
[ __ ] subgenre that just
went crazy and blew up and inspired all
the youth passed away
yep that's depression as [ __ ]
for everybody that is supposed to be
like
the the young foundation moving into the
next generation
in terms of listeners they were all
devastated had
nothing to be inspired on which is why
i feel like a lot of the females
in the game is getting the opportunity
now cause it was such a wide open window
you know what i'm saying somebody like
megan came in who understood the
internet who was going viral who did all
the [ __ ] anime
weeaboo [ __ ] but then also had the music
of course people
lashed onto that [ __ ] it was just it was
so good so i think that's tight because
i honestly think women
in rap are like [ __ ] on the [ __ ]
right i think it's like i think we're
like in the middle of like the female
rapper renaissance like well like this
is like the like we're gonna look back
uh like the last two or three years but
you know that it was so popping
yeah cardi and sweetie and you had
rhapsody yeah you had all these
it's we've never seen it you know like
forever it was just nikki
period yeah before that it was like foxy
and you know i mean there was a you know
the 90s you know it was the brad foxy
missy
but like for like 12 years it was just
nicki minaj
and then you know i remember she i think
she won the bet female rapper of the
year where like
nine years straight or some [ __ ] she was
the only one she was the only one
but she was awesome but my thing is
though cuz i just had a debate with
somebody
about this uh
just because she was the only one though
don't take away from
how much of a legend she was because
that's what a lot of people like to say
she's the greatest of all time female
wise
sane i just don't i don't even think
there's a discussion i think you could
you could say lauren hill based off
of the score and miss education but as
far as like
i think lauren hill's a a a more uh
complete artist like all around right
you know what i'm saying because she
could obviously we're talking about
emcee like nikki like
barred out hover monster do we do people
actually imagine laura hill out wrapping
nicki minaj on something though like
i think she could make a better song
relatively
probably better album yeah but like can
she outrap nikki
i always say like yo just listen to
monster like nikki destroyed
peak ross peak hove peak kanye
bro do you do i mean i'm an oakland
[ __ ] so i come from the i'm a function
baby
in the function if nicki minaj remixed a
song i don't give a [ __ ] who song it was
wayne jay-z
when she did when she first came out she
did that she remember when she did the
dunk remix the soldier boy [ __ ]
i was on the plane with dwayne i know
the verse trust me
nikki's the goat yeah she's a gold she
the goat i think she just became a
little bit
unlikable definitely and
i just don't think that cardi thing
helped her because cardi was so likable
so it makes people think like forget
like history almost like hey like
yeah cardi's hot and she's much more
likable than nicki but like you can't
just erase a decade of dominance from
like yeah i mean
yeah um i think that's a problem
that uh that a lot of og's
face in the game is is the
jay-z quote uh will you live long enough
to see yourself
become a villain you're the dire hero
you live long enough to see yourself
become a villain
and i think that's just an inevitable in
rap
look at everybody who we used to
champion that even i
call myself roasting sometimes but i i
don't actually mean but like [ __ ] to
talk [ __ ] amongst friends you know what
i'm saying
like eminem ludacris all these people
who had all this type of success
but like just when people get old bro
they just
aren't cool as they used to be you know
what i'm saying that's just how i go
that's life
i'm i'm less cool definitely i i
definitely feel like
that happened with m i feel like the
album he dropped last year was
was his best album in like 10 years but
i feel like there was just a block of
eminem's
career the last decade where we were
just like nobody want to hear this [ __ ]
but he's still rapping at a superior
level yeah no i mean he's a [ __ ]
all-time great
i just don't think the music just i
don't know some of the [ __ ] he was
putting out like you know you could like
look at some artists like royce the five
nine who's as old as am who's
but was has been putting out dope music
and in my opinion as uh just a fan of
everything that i've heard from royce
that i chose to listen to because i'm
not like a super
right voice head or anything but like i
feel like
lyrically he he why he
he on the same dojo level as eminem 100
100 like you can't play me a song to
prove me wrong about it you're right
about that
royce is a goat bro he's one of the most
slept on dudes ever
yeah um shout out to roy he got a lot of
love
for the town too he showed oakland a lot
of love and you know cause detroit and
oakland got that
that kind of synergy what is the synergy
because there is a synergy between
detroit and oakland what is it
exactly you know it's it's deeper rooted
into the history of
music the car business um
and travel about why we got
the bay area got this direct connection
to
motor city you know what i'm saying but
um
aside from that and like just the
history of business and infrastructure
we just really align our
personal values the same way that [ __ ]
from detroit do
like the same way they talk to women in
the same way they like to go put on
cartiers and have sideshows like
we either started it and showed it to
them
and they started stuff and showed it to
us it's always been this
cultural exchange of
just really regionally specific habits
that we share with detroit
yeah i had that conversation uh you know
uh you know empire
has a bunch of detroit artists yeah and
it's like ghazi was like yo there's a
connection
mm-hmm and i was like and i was like yo
there is like when you really think
about it
yeah no just the energy is very it's
it's just all the beats
that them [ __ ] just own it sound real
similar
and when they started uh coming into
like the
the internet underground
area of like listener and really start
having their moments
then oakland started taking from the
beach that they was on there's even like
two always a back and forth if you think
about oakland too like
or the bay historically there's been
like two sides of the music game
like in the 90s there was like the
rbo posse 40 too short mac dre [ __ ] but
then on the other side it was like
hieroglyphics
yeah and like a lot of backpack [ __ ] and
destroying
the same [ __ ] detroit's like the
hardcore street [ __ ] or there's j
dilla and slum village and royce and you
know it's
two two two two separate sides of the
coin um
sonically for both cities um we were
talking about female rappers earlier who
who's like a female mc who who
who obviously nicky aside but like who's
somebody who you want to tap in with uh
tierra whack tear wax fire yeah she's
from philly right
i think so yeah she's fire i believe so
we've only met once
and it was it was all love i'll be
fanning out
i don't even hide it when i really be a
fan of somebody i gotta let them know so
i seen i met her at uh
at the homie amber's birthday shout out
amber
um and it was just it was hella cool
i really just want to be like please get
in the studio with me but i try to be
cool
oh yeah i'm a big fan man
when's the last time you fanned out with
somebody um
i feel like i'm missing something i feel
like it was a time recently
where it happened who have i met
recently
or short too short it was it was uh
i was in oakland we're too short
and two [ __ ] eating some five fish at
a place in in
alameda it was a double date uh no
i mean something it was really like too
short and two holes and i was
and you were there yeah yeah yeah
so you were the third wheel in the in
the four-legged situation there
oh but trust me
i got that i got that third wheel
rolling though real fast that is like
that there's something to be said that
like you're hanging out with too short
of course you'd have two [ __ ]
like that that doesn't disappoint like
you know this is right on brand
bruh so i'm we're we're like three slush
margaritas down
it's starting to beat my ass so i'm like
trying to take it slow i'm eating hell
of the [ __ ] fish i flip it over
that's how much of the fish i'm eating
yeah and he looked at me he said
uh yeah i'm with this [ __ ] right now
i'm like what cuz he's been on facetime
this whole time i just been
entertaining the host and he turned the
phone and he put me on facetime
is him e40 ice cube and snoop dogg
and then he just take his airpods out
hand it to me and i don't know
nothing about what they were talking
about or nothing
and then and 40 going hard talking about
what's up he's showing me love
snoop instantly was like what's up
netflix
ice cube ice cube is like who is this
guy hella [ __ ]
menacing but he was showing me love at
the same time but he was so see he was
literally like this
he was like yeah no short was telling us
no i see i see i i never heard of you
but i'm finna check you out
cause snoop said you creative and i was
like
oh no you know i'll be i'll be making
content [ __ ]
mister you gotta be in the next friday
i heard chris tucker doesn't want to be
in it he's acting as [ __ ] and then snoop
and short was like man you should direct
the whole video i was like if y'all give
me a song to do it i'll do it
for sure do it for free yeah i'll do it
please let me do it
but um that was probably my my last star
struck moment for sure
oh yeah that face time's crazy it was
tight too because it was really
christening me like nah
if short it's giving you the okay snoop
already did it 40 partially did it
now all right cube's on board
we [ __ ] with you it means a lot to me
how disappointed would you be if when
you went to hang out with too short he
introduced you to his wife
that he's been with for like 20 years
and like two small children of his
and he was like hey hey this is my wife
yeah these are my kids let's go to
applebee's yeah like wouldn't that be a
little disappointing
and it's like like a white lady with a
with a bob yeah like she's like hi
daddy yeah
[Laughter]
what's this falcon about yeah the type
of lady who
wear like my son is my king shirts i saw
sugar freeze
i saw sugar free in vegas with two
[ __ ]
on leashes of course and i was like this
is
thank you this is what i'm this is why
this this is how i
i run into sugar free at the planet
hollywood walking through the [ __ ]
mall with [ __ ] two females on leashes
and i'm just like yeah i just got i'm
glad to know sugar-free still going
strong i'm glad to know that
that pimping is eternal it is eternal it
will never die
i can't like if i saw sugar free walking
through
planet hollywood holding hands with a
female
i'd have been like damn i was still
would have been like fell off living off
the bench you know what
i was in the hands bro yeah on the
leashes
can you imagine the white people walking
by who had no idea who this this guy
was it was it was hilarious were you a
sugar-free fan
sugar free is like an acquired taste uh
i [ __ ] with all
all of the flavor rap like we we had one
sugar-free song on a cd
and that's how i knew who sugar free was
when you like would make the napster mix
cds and [ __ ] back in the day it was the
one where he's beating on the table
[Music]
yeah it was that song so we listed that
[ __ ] over we had that
and get stupid this was how i first
heard the song get stupid was on that cd
that was it who made them who made the
cd my little cousin sunnyboat
it was his cd i think he took it from
somebody his older brother um
i missed the days where we'd like just
get random cds in your car you'd be like
what's this
yeah [ __ ] interesting new songs
you've never heard of you're like oh
[ __ ] yeah
those were the days it was tight um
that's how i learned about sugarfree was
a fan
ever since as soon as he as soon as i
heard i'd rather give you my [ __ ] yeah
can i
i said oh man that that's dedication to
the paper if i ever seen it you could
take my whole
[ __ ] man just don't take my weed or my
money take the [ __ ] please
have her that's great yo interrupting
your podcast experience
to tell you about our sponsor odd socks
by the way man can we just talk about
how amazing odd socks is as a company
not only do they give you the most
comfortable socks
in the world um they also have like you
know they got ric flair socks
they got [ __ ] spongebob socks for the
children if you're into oreos you know
shout out to all the fat [ __ ] out there
they got oreo socks they got pepsi socks
these are probably my favorites the
scarfaces
listen they got all kinds of [ __ ] going
on at odd socks not to mention
they just launched underwear they got
slippers they got masks
and on the most comfortable socks in the
world you got to get the odd socks
basics and thank me later
go to oddssocks.com it's actually not
even on socks.com i should know it by
now [ __ ] it's odd socksofficial.com
oddsoxofficial.com oddsoxofficial.com
keywordbootleg kev and you'll save 20
off your final order
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kev
go to oddssoxofficial.com and spend some
[ __ ] money and support the podcast
they're good people i said oh we yo
how much was a little bee in the base
[ __ ] obviously
even before that um you know i always
say that the pack
really influenced la sound
mm-hmm for sure because it was the i
feel like the packaging and the fashion
i feel like the pack was doing a lot of
like what ended up being mustard sound
first mm-hmm um uh
and shout out to league of stars and
those guys but i always thought
sonically the pack was doing that [ __ ]
first but then you know little b had his
run where he was putting out a trillion
mixtapes and
just kind of became this [ __ ] cult
figure yeah um how big
how big of an influence was like you
know i'm sure that [ __ ] hit different in
the bay like i was living in vegas when
the when the cooking and all that [ __ ]
was going on
and the [ __ ] was big there with the kids
but yeah i can only imagine
in the bay where i mean to me it was so
big it felt
already like legendary it felt like um
it just felt like little b was this
intangible
unreachable entity that did
and said whatever he wanted to say as an
internet baby from the bay
i loved it i praised it i still do i
think little b
is till this day one of the most
influential rappers
in hip-hop ever every top 100 list needs
to have a little b
on it i don't give [ __ ] feet 100 but
like
his impact had generational
ripples same same thing as chief key for
the way
people give chief keef that praise
little b right there yeah i feel like a
little b was like the first uh
you know if you think about the era we
were just talking about like that 2016
i feel like like a little like all of
them kids took from like little b
riff raff like there was like that old
like those internet figures that were
just doing
crazy [ __ ] it wasn't as much about the
music as it was about
the person they were the antics yeah
yeah it was uh
that was before the antics became doing
things to yourself
true you know what i'm saying that was
just doing things it was just like yo
look at this dude
all these [ __ ] are telling him
he could they could [ __ ] his like you
could [ __ ] my [ __ ]
that's when that's when it was real like
back when riffraff who i also take
influence from and
me me and riff have had conversations
about love refresh
he's hilarious um if if he would have
came out five
six years later he'd be so much bigger
bro he'd be he'd be the number one need
because he's [ __ ]
he was like the crossover into when
people started doing [ __ ] to myself but
i i mean like he should have died you
know
the tattoo he had a [ __ ] world
started he pioneered that for real
definitely for real and people don't
bring that [ __ ] up
now what i say it was it went as far as
like a little b
or chief even turns into influence of
course no no no but he was definitely on
the forefront
yeah for that he was doing a lot of i'm
a fan of all of them [ __ ] man i [ __ ]
i [ __ ] with all of it the riffraff uh
[ __ ] there was a record he did with
action bronson called bird on a wire
that harry fraud produced that was like
oh this [ __ ] is fire yeah yeah it came i
i i also liked the one he did with
mustard
we were slapping yup how to be a boss or
how to be somebody how to be the man
yeah how to be a man i just loved his
videos where he would just
go on rants and talk about like middle
of my like i got this lamp from brazil
like ain't no middle of the mall
[ __ ] and you want to know i always like
that i always been attracted to that
because
mac dre does that too short does that
another influence of mine dom kennedy
doesn't know all the shout outs
where [ __ ] just start talking about
their life yeah
black gold black globes sitting on a
cherrywood desk
yeah i got this [ __ ] from i got this
[ __ ] from bermuda you know
what i'm saying like that's hella clean
to me yeah yeah yeah
that's some real [ __ ] who was on your
album man it
is just the homies it's just people who
care about me and love me
i do got a lot of homies so i got to be
more specific uh bj the chicago kids on
there
the homie tisch hyman is on there um the
the fellow pedestrian and filipino pilot
is on there only right and buddy is on
there buddy's [ __ ] another
just legend and like buddy don't get
enough love he don't
and that's why i'm making sure that uh
i like i like to keep him as one of my
honest to
true god friends who like goes out his
way to check up on me and my mental
health
i believe i really i believe one one
night i was djing in hollywood at
playhouse and you buddy and a.d
rolled up randomly it was my birthday
yeah that was my bet when i put the
champagne on the hose in the front
and i remember just like i forget what
buddy record had just dropped but it
definitely wasn't the song to play at
playhouse
but i ran that [ __ ] yeah you ran we went
up it was tight
it was like it was that was my first uh
my first like live birthday out here
because
my first birthday that while i was
living out here i went back to the bay
it's kind of somber i was like making
this transition so i've been out here a
year
and i was like [ __ ] it man i know all
these clubs i want to just give me the
[ __ ] rapper table on the side yeah go
have fun
i'm trying to do it so i hit everybody
the playhouse was the last stop we had
did a whole our whole rounds
playhouse was the last stop and i had
that table
and i called everybody it's like it's my
birthday everybody said this nobody said
no
right everybody said my people yeah we
pulling i don't remember if that was
when a.d got his horse teeth or not
i don't know no it was prior prior to
his teeth i always clown 80s to you
i always say he could eat corn on the
cob any better than any rapper ever he
could chew ice
oh he pasted he could chew and he do a
lot with those teeth
i think his teeth need their own podcast
he just launched this podcast yeah
80s teeth need their own they need their
own pockets he could have been standing
that table with the [ __ ] uh milk
[ __ ]
yeah oh that's great shout out to a.d
man that's my brother i love that
i love a.d she just went in the other
day yeah he's beating him simba
and cass got simba i was just with simba
oh yeah you were casting uh in pasadena
yeah yeah symbol left
my spot and then went over there so yeah
shout out to simba he's he's another bay
area guy
yeah finally getting some love man yeah
been out for a long time i'd love to see
it he was out before me
yeah he didn't deal before i even was in
the industry so
i'm super happy to see him get his light
and his love
100 um
you mentioned moving to la i feel like
there's there's cert there's people who
move to la and let this [ __ ] kind of
like consume them because it
there it is there is some truth to like
the
stigma of like artists or youtubers or
tick tockers or whatever that come to la
and just the world that you could get
wrapped up in and the things that that
you might
you know that might carry more weight to
you here because you're here that really
don't matter
yeah like did you find like like moving
to l.a did
was there any sort of period of time
where you felt you know like
overwhelmed with this [ __ ] boy [ __ ] i
feel kind of overwhelmed right now it's
like a constant
state of being overwhelmed and adapting
it it's how far you want to go what
level are you trying to adapt to
for yourself your own personal goals in
your career and your
mental happiness but it's never going to
stop until you become like a legacy act
but even then these these people these
artists have just
built the infrastructure around them to
deal with that constant like
mental attack because it's that forever
and the internet will
solidify that [ __ ] because when you're
not dealing with the sauce to get lost
in the outside you're dealing with it on
your phone yeah
you're dealing with in your email on
zoom calls you know what i'm saying like
that this [ __ ] is forever that's the job
so it's about how much you want to take
and like i said it's some [ __ ] that i
got to deal with currently
and until i figure it's like absolutely
too much
then maybe i'll do that but i have been
thinking about um
just getting another spot somewhere to
like
clear myself for this la [ __ ] especially
because
when you live in la you still gotta deal
with
being a transplant because i'm not from
here i
know a lot of people from here and i
respect their rules and regulations of
that game however
but like you you still gotta be in this
city and
and navigate such the thickness of the
sauce
and it's crazy because the world shut
down so you're trying to navigate in the
same way that you guys
when the world was open especially here
yeah really shut the [ __ ] down it shut
the [ __ ] down so it's like damn
why am i even here i'm dealing with all
of this [ __ ] just to like be here i
don't even need to be here right now
yeah the homie uh i got a homie uh who's
a rapper mike stud and he
he um he just said [ __ ] it and he went
to arizona for like two months and now
he's in montana
he's just like he's like i gotta get the
[ __ ] out of la man like if there's a
time to just take a break and unplug
it's like
while everything's shut down yeah i go
to the bay
uh tomorrow to shoot a short film
connected to this album
it's gonna be four episodes about my
origin story
me growing up like becoming when i first
started scamming like
we got a little boy to play me as a kid
it's gonna be like a whole crazy
movie yeah no it's a short it's like an
actual like a short film like a real
yeah uh i i just seen the email i think
we're premiering them if we're going on
bt and hella [ __ ]
this is like a whole it's a thing like
is 88 rising handling the production and
all that
don't know i'm going out there to
seriously act
i got all my friends ready and they've
been doing are they playing themselves
it's the only way to do it we gotta put
the whole come on come on guys put my
[ __ ] on
yeah um and it's something that we've
always wanted to do so i'm happy that i
can cross this off the bucket list
for everybody you know what i'm saying
like we always seriously wanted to
tell our story because i come from
a crazy place and i'm a crazy [ __ ] so
like
i always wanted to tell that and this is
a good time to at least tell like the
general oil like a good
portion of that right after that i fly
instantly to hawaii to shoot the last
music video for this album
and then after that i'm just done i'm
doing press what island are you shooting
in hawaii
i don't even know yet that's the hey
look man shoot all your videos in hawaii
i want to just stay out there actually i
haven't been to hawaii since i was
pimping
i went out there to pimp a couple years
ago well listen wait wait a minute it's
not let's not gloss over the pimping
so he was actually pimping i'm from the
bay
well i mean i know that is natural to
the babe so how old are you
28 so you're 28 so you're pimping in an
era
because when i was a kid we used to
drive up and down the strip in phoenix
there's a street called van buren
down the blade yeah and we used to like
[ __ ] would be walking there'd be
pimps on every corner
and we would just like prank hookers
like
you know just [ __ ] with hookers almost
got killed a couple of times yeah you
know
chased down by pimps we're [ __ ]
throwing water balloons at hoes and [ __ ]
we're just doing dumb [ __ ] we're like
some [ __ ] jackass [ __ ]
yeah um but then that [ __ ] went away
because
craigslist yeah and the internet started
popping
so was that that was like your era of
the pimp [ __ ] like how did you get into
pimping i mean
it first of all pimping got into me i
didn't get in the pimping
the sauce really chose me and that's
just how i go
being back from the bay when you're
shining you look good
you handsome you're not white somebody
gonna come pay you
somebody it's a [ __ ] out there that i
want to pay you she can't wait
so did you have like a bottom [ __ ] yeah
i did
that was like your man she was solid too
honestly i just don't have
the i don't care it's hard
i really don't care and it's it was hard
to
go through the motions of pimping
because you got to respect the game
and that's something not to be played
with because it don't change it's
forever though those rules is written in
stone
and you got to respect that and i knew
that because i didn't want to come in
disrespectful but at the same time
i had to consider like do i care enough
to respect
it if i'm in it and i don't because i'm
a scammer so like
i don't want to call you if i just
knocked your business she paid me the
fee
and now she want to come up under me i
don't care to call you and respect the
game
because if i'm looking how long did that
last like how long was that era of
couple years
it was i was on and off with it i never
was like
all the way down stomped down in the mud
so would you have like
you know just [ __ ] posted up at
hotels with the online ads booming like
that's really what it was and then back
page got shut down
i pivoted after that and uh
i just started having the [ __ ]
running to the stores i was tired of
this [ __ ]
tricks is dirty and the way
that hoes like to live in the bay is
just too
it's just it exposed me to too many
people i don't like to be around
and i'm a super social [ __ ] i'd love a
company you should see my house now
but it's just was like i saw a picture
of your bedroom on your ig look stellar
stellar bedroom thank you thank you i
just got a new rug today look i'll show
you a pic
uh i feel like anybody you pick up at
the uh is it called the above the clouds
festival
uh head in the club in the clouds like
any of those lovely young asian women
would walk into your room and be like oh
my god
this is it yeah they do it all the time
oh that's fire that's a rug
that's fire huge too it's about it's
about here to here that's
dope yeah scam boy yeah
that's good that's in the bedroom uh-huh
i'm trying to figure out a place to put
it on the floor
so when you were when you when you were
pimpin what was like your
stable like the most amount of women at
one time that were
three that's good i was my i was foot in
foot out it wasn't
how many unders well help me understand
this because i don't think people truly
understand like the business model of
pimping right yeah like what is your
purpose
in the girl besides taking her money no
i mean
it's more than purpose it's everything
i'm everything
i not only am i the purpose uh
i'm also the consequence i'm the cause
and any effect i'm the alpha and omega
in this situation like i'm your daddy
your boyfriend
your manager your day-to-day
everything i'm everything so so any
services that they need you could they
could hit you like yo this trick's not
he
he's not he's not paying or yeah uh
i [ __ ] caught gonorrhea and i need to
go get the shot
yeah i need you to take me to the clinic
or pay for this [ __ ] man i won't [ __ ]
with no dirty
but yo but i'll be [ __ ] in the in the uh
you know i'm assuming that there's
even if a girl is clean there's a chance
that that could happen in that field
i mean but the thing is what a lot of
people don't really know is
a lot a lot of like divisions that's
really in the game
is some of the cleanest safest
women humans i've heard that
zero experience but you gotta think who
has chlamydia
like rappers have chlamydia [ __ ] like
me in a club
got commedia yeah that just been [ __ ]
thousands of hoes
not like the indian [ __ ] on craigslist
not the [ __ ]
mexican dude not the dentist yeah you
know what i'm saying like they don't
have
right gonorrhea that's you paying for
[ __ ] right
right right right right it's not like
it's not like these girls are [ __ ]
[ __ ] like random dudes at playhouse
and it's not like they're
homeless like [ __ ] other homeless
people right they're not in [ __ ]
you know they're not downtown l.a taking
shits on the side of the street yeah
like that's what
and then turning tricks out of [ __ ]
that's what people think
right right when they think of that but
like they're not putting no respect on
this
on the sex workers existence they just
they because they
look at the occupation as something
that is so beneath them personally in
their values
they choose to uh to to demonize
um how their perception of that person
and they project that on other people to
where
it's become almost like a standard of
how we think about
women even yeah even mistresses even
strippers get bad reps
like there's like a negative stigma and
it's like for what
another riches [ __ ] out facts steal
don't gotta [ __ ] steal steal they're at
house parties right now
yeah in the hills um just not stopping
with them i was gonna say um
now only fan seems to be like the yeah
tiger loki
tiger you could you might just say
tiger's pimping right now on only fans
uh um because lightweight because we
both uh are legitimate black males i
don't wanna
uh openly well he's managing some only
fans girls we'll call him managing right
right right right he's managing taiga is
in the business of
working very closely with sex
work true and even even at times being a
sex worker himself because i've
accidentally seen his dick on twitter
before
yeah me too yeah i wasn't happy about it
i wasn't happy either i wasn't
it's always the worst when you
accidentally see a dick on your twitter
timeline
it was wednesday too i remember
wednesday i was eating chipotle i still
haven't went back to chipotle
because you think of tiger's dick it's
terrible i saw trey song's dick today on
accident
i've purposely avoided it i muted the
word
trey songz oh you because i didn't want
it you gotta show me how to do that yeah
yeah
yeah yeah it's in the settings on
twitter oh
man are you ever worried about some [ __ ]
like that leaking to you do you have
like all the time
are you worried about it yeah i think uh
any day now some [ __ ] might hit the
internet especially if they got trey
he's been at it for years
if they got him i don't stand a [ __ ]
chance
oh would you ever dabble in the only fan
[ __ ] i'm made and only fans and i
currently have a few subscribers i just
haven't
posted content yet because i'm i'm
trying to work on how i want to approach
it
because you could like you could just
post fan [ __ ] on there
yeah i mean i think i want to do a
plethora of everything like if i got
if it's some genuine hoes out there or
[ __ ] anybody it's only fans i can't keep
track of
who's buying this [ __ ] right somebody
want to get a dick pic for like 200
or something i might post it in the dms
or some [ __ ] later on down the line
if someone wants to pay you 200 for a
dick pic then i would definitely
i've actually been paid more than that
before you've been paid for it hey
we you ever been paid for a dick pic
jesse
no feed pick shane
saying well you know we were talking
earlier you probably have nice feet you
got nice hands boss
super paws um it's gay to say pause is
it
yeah it's gay to say pause and no homo
it's super gay is it super gay yeah so
don't say those
no no okay just let it rock just let it
rock
because otherwise like why'd you bring
it up
that's fair if we start talking about
narcotics and doing illegal [ __ ] right
and i kept saying oh hey no police [ __ ]
but
when you were selling crackle like where
did you you know what i'm saying no
police [ __ ] though
yeah like like no police i hear what
you're saying i hear what you're saying
i'm the police what the [ __ ]
right right right so you keep saying no
homo and paul's like
you're gay i had to stop i had to stop
saying no homo i feel like i didn't age
as well
no i'm a big dipset guy yeah love cam
love love that whole just era of hip hop
and no homo was kind of like
yeah i feel like we got attached to that
though because i
shout out to cameron at cameron little
brother somebody
who often likes to uh i'm in a similar
vein
fashion fashion yeah you guys know what
i'm saying yes
he do a lot and he inspired a lot for me
i don't even feel like he'd say that
[ __ ] right now i don't know if that's
true
i don't know i think i could see him
saying paul's but no homo
i think i think i think he might let
that thing ride still you think so i i
mean
i don't know i i he's one of my bucket
list interviews he's one of the guys
i've never interviewed that's like
there's like four or five and cam's one
of them i'm calling it now because
my art interview was first you have to
bring me up
in your interview with camera okay how
would you like me to bring you up
however you see fit i'll just bring you
to the interview yep
yeah you gotta i'll i'll do the prank
when you when you interview cameron i'll
do the prank see i'm afraid of cameron
though
i'm not i feel like i feel like cam
is still that [ __ ] yeah i feel like
yeah
but you can't you can't go in there with
fear in your heart he appeared boo he
goes
from harlem he's gonna smell it before i
don't know if i prank cam though cuz i
want to interview him like a bunch of
times
yeah you and i are like boys i don't
know cameron
so i might only have one shot to make a
good impression i don't
want to ruin your killer cam experience
now if it was like you know
i'm trying to think of somebody else
whoever the [ __ ] freddie gibbs somebody
who's like my boy like yeah we can prank
him all day but cameron i'm like i want
to make
i was a childhood guy you know he's one
of my guys you know yeah for sure
hey what so take take take me back to
the uh
you know obviously uh you had the uh
viral situation with russ
that went down and i hated to see that
because i'm cool with russ and i'm cool
with you and i feel like you're
one of the most brightest energies in
hip-hop
i really don't and i wasn't privy to
whatever
had been said prior but i was just like
yo you're like who [ __ ] hates you
no i mean just him right it really it
so i don't know what happened like was
there some sort of like
remarks made that like led up to that
because yeah i mentioned him in a song
and he didn't like it
um and it took a while because i was so
i was so mad at the fact that
not only did i in my mind not diss him
i never was trying to diss him but
uh i told him about it i dm'd him
beforehand
son comes out i don't he leaves me on
red and then the first time i see him
i don't even really know him or
how how he looks or nothing i turn
around he's 20
20 [ __ ] [ __ ] after he snaked
me
and i just thought that was wild as like
a [ __ ] as rich as he is
with his network and ability right he
could have came at me different
especially since he knew like it's no
way you planned that because he planned
he was the headline headliner that
festival and he planned
to to see me and have me jump because he
was there early i was one of the openers
right i mean samino was just going we
was midday i wasn't open it was midday
but still
it wasn't the headliner you know what
i'm saying uh
i feel like he could have went about
that way different but he didn't and he
and he chose that route
but at the same time you know as a
grown-ass man i did speak on him
yeah you know he did look at it as i
spoke on him and i he
he always says like you can't tell me
how to uh react to
and i think at that time everyone was
was just
it was like he was getting a lot of i
wasn't trying to down him
i actually had followed him on twitter
and i i thought that russ is
and i still do i think it's really
interesting how some people could have
so much
garner so much success in the industry
and how they navigate
but still not be accepted by the culture
but they
are clearly eating from it and feeding
some things to it
right um so that's what the bar was
about
but he took it as disrespect and
responded accordingly
i can't be mad at uh how he feel about
it
i'm obviously not happy with the outcome
right right
i mean your intention was not malicious
with with the mention
yeah i don't even know him right right
nothing outright diss nobody
was there ever any uh correspondence
with you guys after that
or is it just kind of what it is what it
is keep it moving yeah
it's over it was never no correspondence
about nothing
i just think i think that you know like
i said you're there could have been
you're such a dope energy and and
figured yeah and i feel like
on on on his side too like he's i feel
like he gives so much free game to
artist and he puts out so much dope
quality music
i just think you could i think that
window when everyone was coming at russ
i just think he probably just made notes
of like okay
if if he probably he was on his he was
trying to be on his head man [ __ ]
it's just really unfortunate because in
the in the perfect world
we probably you guys could have made
some fire music together or something
because i know you're friends with jim
but you know he can't be in the room
with russ around me
um you guys have mutual people it's
unfortunate i mean i think i think
hopefully one day you know you guys i
mean honestly at this point it's i don't
even look at it as unfortunately it just
happened
yeah it's like it is what it is and you
know if you guys ever
have some correspondence in the future
cool if not it is what it is
from that uh i had some correspondence
with
with benny the butcher that i'm that i'm
happy we was able to hash out
because i've become a fan of him and
what griselda is doing as a recent
nice tight so from what happened with
russ
you got in contact with benny what like
what like because uh
me and benny had like twitter knows we
had like a small altercation after the
dreamville [ __ ]
and it wasn't we was not cool i didn't
know that
yeah we was not we was not cool and then
the rush [ __ ] happened and he was
you know they they he was going on tour
with russia and he had said something
and uh i just reached out i i
was able to get his number from somebody
else and uh
made it happen connected with him and we
had to we got to talk as grown as
men that's good respect yeah benny and
griselda
it's my fate like between what what
they're doing and what fred's been doing
the last couple years it's like
to me like the best rounds oh i love it
in the world yeah i love it
i feel like the pandemic made people
like in 2020 people were listening to
music differently
because they weren't at the [ __ ] club
they weren't standing on couches
they were like listening in their
headphones or at home or
in the car they were just listening
differently so actually like
that's the only reason why i still exist
it's the only reason why i'm seeing
success now honestly
is because the pandemic forced everybody
to actually
listen to me rap right because everybody
was looking for what my
gimmick record was going to be once when
i was super viral when the drake [ __ ]
was happening
now cole like what's his [ __ ] he's
just gonna have one and he'd be out of
there but it was
they was gonna attach that to some type
of gimmick that [ __ ] was not gonna work
right right they had to pull back accept
that these people still [ __ ] with me
and i'm not like boom ganging myself
who's actually doing really well i just
watched this
follow him on youtube he's like turning
this [ __ ] around yeah good for him good
for him right
but like i wasn't i obviously wasn't
that right
and people got to sit down and listen to
my [ __ ] and be like oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is right cause i'm black belt
at this point just like
trying to now compete against other
dojos and still get better but it's no
more like
drills with me right now well the out
when's the i'm coming out march it's
coming out in march yeah march 19th
assuming we're gonna get the movie after
the album yeah right after
because that's gotta be i mean a lot of
editing and yeah we're talking about a
[ __ ] movie
yeah even if it's like a 10 minute movie
it's you know that's a lot
single comes out next friday yeah on the
12th
that's the one with the better off a
loan sample right yeah that shits fire
it's called how many
i love that record yeah sam played me a
few joints he played me one that pilo
produced that was cool
he played me one that i hated uh it was
like what was that the booty one or some
[ __ ]
booty [ __ ] i don't know oh he played
your demos
probably that's not on the album he so
he played me the pillow record and i was
like
i was like i like this record a lot it
just it's some regional [ __ ] and he was
like well what about this one
and then he played this like booty [ __ ]
and i was like
i'll tell you this i was like yo don't
let him put that song out you hate it
that [ __ ] is not it yeah then he played
the the single and i was like
this [ __ ] is it yeah he had to that
[ __ ] was going through the drafts and
then he found a miss
he played a miss so he had to hit you
with the cream of the crap that [ __ ] is
hard i was like he had to hit you with
this should be like this should be your
biggest record
yeah great record man no i feel like
it's gonna be the biggest record in my
career and i'll
show you the music video after this we
could watch it crazy
yeah let's do it it's ridiculous fire
are you working with um
any of the 88 rising guys on the album
at all like
no i have reached out to uh to brian
to get him on something i see him
everywhere in north hollywood every time
i'm at the grocery store
like shopping for halloween costumes
he's just there like he's at whole foods
every day i think
he said he said that he was working on
some stuff and he wasn't really
recording
would have no idea that he's popping
either if you ran into him in person he
just looks like a like a high school kid
yeah
really for sure he's he's such a genuine
i love brian he's such a genuine dude he
just liked what he liked
yeah he's super passionate about it and
like that's it
what about joji he seems like a very
eclectic individual very interesting cat
i've never met a [ __ ] i don't know him
yo you haven't met him no i i only know
people that know him
like i i'm hella cool with august and uh
he's on ada rising he's super talented
and i know he hella [ __ ] with joji and
[ __ ]
um same thing with brian but i never i
don't know him like that i'm a fan of
his [ __ ] though
he shit's crazy yeah yeah well [ __ ] man
there was a song
that we both was on but we never met but
you haven't linked with them
albums coming out march 17 what 19
19 wait what's the what's the album name
what's the number oh i thought you're
talking about the date no yeah
well you just gave away today march 19th
the albums come out yeah uh no but
they named the album 1176 1176 yeah
boom go get that and uh thanks for the
interview man
thank you for having me it was a long
journey today we started with a prank
and then we ended up having a crazy
interview
yeah super tired perfect i wanted to
give you
a good interview either way you see i
was complaining the blood about you like
bro
i'm trying to do some [ __ ] over here
perfect good that's great man